monsieur et madame villa prend une fille
et monsieur madame les couvertures nos
gratton une fait passer sans la
chanteuse chantal l'olympia j'y vais pas
ont trois enfants
frédéric françois chantal biya françois
chante à l'olympia j'avais peur
pour toi verrou monsieur show pathé
brumath et continue
hochet pour incendies
sur patins
richaud
valentin fils bonsoir
je me gasoil ont un fils monstre au lion
finances un fils
est encore boucher ont un fils est
encore jugé olivier lisier dans
ses poubelles
ont tellement qu'ils me montrent une
fille frêle brel très jeunes filles ont
une fille
francesca voilà et francesca et
monsieur et madame fin ont un fils roger
agile [ __ ] comment ça m'amuse estimé
c'est une brute située qui demande à sa
copine qu'est ce tu lui as demandé au
père noël cette année sa copine lui
répond 100 euros comme d'habitude
maj un jean pour résoudre c'est la
rentrée des classes en 6e donc
georges lanvin 6e cra et ernest renan 6e
b
alain duhamel 6e c'est mohamed larbi
terminale
alain rémond 6e b et ça continue et ça
continue [ __ ] le mohamed il va à la
fin il dit mais monsieur
le principal il y avait la main comme ça
j'ai que 11 ans je peux pas être en
terminale alors l'autre héros lit il dit
mohamed larbi terminal f croatie
vous rigolez horrible et les deux les
deux filles qui sont qui sont à new york
dans un resto rien il ya un mec qui côté
de l'auberge
moi si on a une
fin
mais la mise farida
le niveau moyen des maisons larissa
la semelle est un peu longue
ça tombe bien
donc c'est bien mais qu'est pas de pouce
non mais tu le match parce qu'elle est
comme journée
[Musique]
or donc ça c'est un groupe de
spermatozoïdes sont dans les écoutes
d'un make way et donc il ya le chef il
monte sur l'estrade de chef il est comme
les gremlins il à la crête comme ça
c'est comme les chefs des gremlins il
monte il à son micro test est un 1 1 2
mes amis ce soir l'homme visera la femme
ouais tout le monde crie et oui c'est
comme ça un milliard à crier tout
cuisinera une capote
mais nous la percevons ouais
bon c'est le bordel le soir venu ils
sont là ils poussent le chef l'état
allait pousser mais poussez poussez qui
poussent ils poussent ils poussent et
poussent allez allez allez ça marche pas
non demain soir et remonte sur l'estrade
à les énerver la nuit le bon dos comme
rambo comme ça est complètement hainard
mélamine et les traces de son bref les
nervures des musées a mis hier nous
avons échoué mais ce soir lors leur
maison enfin moi
il est tout petit il est un peu comme
sarkozy les petits
le mini crois quoi mais il aura une
capote ville m
mais nous la percevons roi
alors c'est le bordel il s'échauffe tous
et où ils font des pompes tout ça c'est
vraiment le bordel le sort ne me pousse
à aller les mecs allait aller et tous
doivent duc et aurait détruisit vous
allez allez allez il peut aussi pousser
pousser une petite fille suri fallu une
petite fille
commence à tous courir lui conclu que
cette histoire je vais en éclaireur il y
va il pas 1h 2h 3h à la et commence à
s'installer sur les coins les autres 14
68 100 m qu'est ce qu'il fout le patron
plein merde ton époux c'est tout il
attendit attendait rien qui est monté
sur une des parois comme ça il fait est
légal je vois un truc arrive au loin et
où ils seraient de resto c'est tout donc
la seconde elle chef qui arrive tout
cabossé tous à la craie de foot une
bande au parti enfin il est carbo c est
comme ça il va presque mourir il fait
lrgp un foyer alors il fait on est dans
la merde
tu connais la différence entre deux
minutes de son ami et deux minutes de
fellation non tu as deux minutes
à type arrive chez un chat quincaillier
heavy bonjour monsieur n'a marché
mondial mais attention quand même aidé
klingmann à pikine en mai encore
oui mais ce que vous pouvez préciser oui
mais comment donnant que
les mirettes
le
le rédiger je suis allé voir en magasin
il s'adresse aux
au vieux magazine et dit agassi il dit
pourquoi écoute des montures avec lui
quelques instants look si on ressort
avec son pack et moins jeunes arméniens
alors il va voir le magazine nîmes
tu as compris ce qu'il voulait oui mais
s'il ne vient pas en
reste et 1
c'est un canard il arrive fatigué il va
dans un bar entre dans le bar le canard
en dans le bas et puis mon auto tabouret
puis fait souffler il avait une aile
comme ça il fait trouver une pression
pression
nous mettrions avec regarde déjà entendu
le canard vous demandez une bière
il fait perdre on fait les deux et
une pression
j'avais fait tout de suite il dessert sa
pression je suivrai les codes et règles
et les impressions avec un an et prend
là bien
ça fait du bien après une journée comme
la mienne il dit je bosse à côté
je suis plombier sur le chantier du côté
c'est le pitch de mon film
dix huit 18 plombier sur le chantier
d'un côté on démarre à chantier là à
côté
facile à la poussière ça fait du bien de
boire une bière et le mec lovech
serveurs saurait dire ok d'accord oui
oui très bien bon le canard
demain canard manière bien
18h pour le boulot c'est bon ça va
ce soit le canard a tout dit baird se
blesse sur une petite pression et du
cerf la pression des canards et bois
fait froid en ce moment il me fait froid
oui c'est sûr bon il canard bien tout ça
toute la semaine le week end arrive via
un circuit qui s'installe dans la ville
et l'homme et l'homme le mec le patron
du bistrot et 18,1 j'ai un canard il va
voir le directeur du cirque il dit j'ai
un mec extra canard c'est un truc
extraordinaire
il vient il parle il parle il y un
canard qui parlait libre et des bières
et vient tous les soirs actif et le
maître patron du reiki mais ça
m'intéresse aux canards qui parlent ce
extraordinaire rio d'intérim à capter
tout
qui lui donne il donne la carte tout le
gard à part il attend le lundi à le
chantier tout ça
le canard le sort du chantier il
arrivait direct mais une bien s'il te
plaît il fait voilà j'ai parlé de vous
au directeur du cirque qui dit voilà je
vous donne sa carte vrai que vous
l'appeliez tout ça et il est très
intéressé et le canard fait qu'est-ce
que tu es qui floute avec un plombier
sait toujours pas si c'est un mec qui
veut apprendre qu'habitat l'angleterre
qui veut apprendre l'anglais mais pas du
tout
pimpant mais le terme gérer sans doute
est ce un chômeur c'est un chômeur
chômage et toutes façons c'est la peau
c'est de trouver du boulot un temps il
faut être bilingue il faut apprendre
l'anglais c'est impossible le journal y
voit là apprenaient leur mue en une
semaine quatre mille euros devenez
probablement mis lundi en une semaine de
7000 euros apprenait sortait
parfaitement l'anglais 8 millions je
peux pas je peux pas mais c'est
impossible donc sera jamais et puis
comment il va faire un journal y voit
donner totalement bilingue en une
chienne apprenez l'anglais
50 euros dit [ __ ] c'est une faute de
cocu il y va quand même exiger
il va il frappe à la porte du mec toc
toc mc ouvrent la porte il fait excuser
moi j'ai pour le l'annoncé dans le
journal je vivais à une erreur de
marquer à devenez bilingue apprenez
l'anglais parfaitement en une semaine
c'est bien ici mais cliff édifice
between
ces deux hippopotames dans l'heure qui
sont dans la brousse et ils arrivent ils
plongent dans une mare de boue comme ça
ils sont là les deux hippopotames ya le
premier gp il crache de la boule au tiff
et y tape dans la boue ils se poussent
les moustiques
y en a un qui s'arrête comme ça et
l'autre continue y fait beau
s'arrête et regarde notre vie il est
hélas tu dis ben j'arrive toujours pas à
me faire à l'idée qu'on est jeudi
dans un bar effet un
whisky souffler alors que ça commence
la porte du whisky aucune bois poursuit
fait un deuxième appelait avant que ça
commence
monsieur sur un deuxième plan complet ap
ap ap ap ap une troisième sous peine
trois coupes - 3e avant que ça commence
4e avant que ça commence 5 6 8 10 ou du
du 10e rang qui fait le dixième un
whisky souple mais qu'il salue ce qu'il
me suit va falloir payer et voilà ça
commence
c'est quoi c'est bien celle de vieux
kinnear qu'elle n'en sa chambre comme ça
et tous les gamins fois oui mais c'est
l'histoire l'histoire
issoire ta gueule
il décède
il digère et à l'épaule qui dirigea le
taillan safari en afrique c'est bien en
afrique c'est bien j'avais ce fusil les
hauts murs ça leur teneur alors je vois
devant moi
oui c'est bien là
j'ai pas mangé sa fiche à lyon j'ai tiré
mon fusil
c'est quoi arriver ta gueule
le lit on me saute dessus et s'arrête à
10 cm arrêtâmes envisage en
effet alors et alors il fait
mais l'union qui l'a tuée mais oui non
mais là je suis et où
je veux bien mais tu as les gemmes
nathalie race
à tostat ma femme aille à la wii
c'est tout ça lovato
sarthois petit chéri d'amour qui
la connaît
bach à mozart 1 terrasse de café
serveurs car il veut
monsieur bah qu'est ce que vous rendrai
moi qui fais
[Musique]
5 donnez moi un débit ok j'ai mon chien
motards bah alors l'avoir 5h bombe of
baby come back
je te la donne au sud
cadeau
ce johnny moi c'est lui qui me l'a
raconté bah ça lui est arrivé donc c'est
normal
oui il va dans un bain dans un
supermarché ces gens qui pendant les
vacances l'a décidé dans un supermarché
ce que
bon vous faire les courses maintenant on
est en vacances il fait les courses il
pousse le cas dit elle est ici à côté et
où il pousse le caddie pousse le caddie
machin est il pour les trucs et tout et
puis il ya les mecs dans ce supermarché
qui distribue les
ddd biftons de tombola comme ça il
emmène dans le cas vis et tout est ici à
le point d'outils continuer un peu
grande dame autour c'est johnny qui dans
un supermarché et il entend micro ou de
devis minutes et l'onu
[Musique]
évidemment les tice et lui fait johnny
c'est toi tu as ta le numéro tu fais mon
fou je vais pas y aller mais si si
balsillie va compter non je dis toi et
il y 20 et le mec déjà brûlé surpris de
voir johnny tu vois combien comment
gagner alors à temps il a gagné son toit
il en faisait d'abord nous allons madrid
a gagné son poids en chocolat bon
son poids parce que c'est la promo aux
noix de coco chocolat noix de coco
et et 150 euros par jour
150 euros par jour moins de temps
jusqu'à ce qu'il fit des outils
[Applaudissements]
là
le valais
[Applaudissements]
et
si claude merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous je m'étais un
peu ce bleu